you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
johnson's call to the world the prime
minister urges humankind to grow up and
come of age at november's cop 26 summit
mr johnson also took issue with kermit
the frog for the muppets insistence that
it's not easy being green in our daily
debate we'll ask which of the two of
them is right
and we'll go behind the doors of the
merseyside school that's leading the
drive to make students aware of climate
change and the ways to tackle it
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
and first of all congratulations if you
stayed up until the small hours of this
morning to watch boris johnson address
the united nations general assembly if
you didn't don't worry we'll be looking
at it in some detail for you now
so the prime minister urged humankind to
grow up and come of age ahead of
november's cop 26 climate summit in
glasgow which he reiterated would
concentrate on four central themes
we need all countries every single one
of you
to step up and commit to very
substantial reductions by 2030
and i absolutely convinced i
passionately believe that we can do it
by making commitments in four areas
and i want you to remember them coal
cars cash and trees coal cars cash and
trees very simple
so let's take a look then at those four
key areas that need tackling firstly
coal now the prime minister wants
countries to end their support of the
fossil fuel
he called on world leaders to phase out
their use of coal power both at home and
overseas
thank very much president xi of china
for what he has just done to end china's
international financing of coal and i
hope china will now go further and phase
out the domestic use of coal as well
wouldn't that be a great thing
because the experience of the uk shows
that it can be
done well next up is cars and mr johnson
has said he wants other countries to
follow the uk's lead and commit to
phasing out the sale of new petrol and
diesel vehicles the uk has promised to
do this by
2030. we call on the world to come
together to drive this market in a
low carbon uh way drive this market so
that by 2040 there are only
zero emission vehicles on sale anywhere
in the world
cash is another big priority for the
prime minister he's asked the world's
richest nations to recommit to spend one
billion pounds a year to help the rest
of the world tackle climate change and
several countries announced that they
would increase their climate finance
commitments during the un general
assembly
i'm very pleased and encouraged by some
of the pledges we've heard here at unger
including from denmark and now
a very substantial commitment from the
united states
that brings us within touching distance
of that 100 billion dollar pledge that
we need every
and finally trees the prime minister is
asking leaders to work together to
reverse the loss of trees and
biodiversity across the world and he's
asked leaders to follow the example of
pakistan's president imran khan who's
pledged to plant 10 billion trees in his
country
we need to halt and reverse the loss of
trees and biodiversity by 2030. halton
reverse the loss of trees by 2030.
that's what we should do uh in uh a
pledge to do that at the the cop in just
40 days time
so that's the thrust of boris johnson's
pitch ahead of the summit which is now
just 39 days away but are his fellow
world leaders likely to listen let's see
what our climate change correspondent
hannah thomas peter thinks sana boris
johnson there wanting commitments and
action from world leaders so will they
have taken notice
they might well have done i think
there's definitely a sense if you speak
to people involved in the negotiations
not just for the uk but for other
countries that there is a renewed sense
of momentum and optimism following that
big new commitment from china to end
international financing for coal uh and
um and so on but that there is a sense
as well that there is a long way to go
we are 40 days away or so
and on coal
you know china and india and australia
and russia big consumers and producers
are yet to reach agreement
about how to phase out uh coal
domestically that's a big problem for
developing nations
um and then on cash we're still 15
billion dollars short of the 100 billion
dollars that was previously promised
from rich nations to give to poorer
nations in order for them to adapt to
the worst effects of climate change 15
billion dollars uh is an obvious thing
to say is still a huge amount of money
so that's even with the big new u.s
commitment and it's it's hard to
overstate really how important uh that
funding shortfall is to developing
nations who really aren't willing to
consider embracing tougher carbon
emissions targets for example until um
that funding gap has has been closed so
there are some big problems there and
then if you look sort of more broadly
these negotiators know that they're
still waiting for some 60 or so
countries to bring forth their
nationally determined contributions
which essentially is under the paris
agreement an enhanced commitment to do
more to reduce carbon emissions that's
called the ratchet mechanism it's what
uh all the countries 190 countries who
signed the paris agreement signed up for
they're supposed to be coming forward
with these enhanced commitments 60 of
them haven't yet and a big part of the
glasgow meeting is to get everyone to
agree on global global carbon markets
and there's been very little progress on
that very sticky thorny issue that's
proving very hard to navigate
and what about the way in which he
delivered his pitch hannah very familiar
boris johnson style even referencing one
of the muppets i mean is that likely to
cut through
well it was the speech that launched a
thousand memes when the internet loved
the kermit the frog analogy um in that
way it did cut through and yes it was
very boris johnson slightly meandering
slightly comical and sometimes a little
bit hard to follow
um
but you know the government has form on
on this subject allegra stratton the
prime minister spokesperson for the cop
26 meeting recently came in for a lot of
criticism when she did a couple of
interviews and referred to how we can
all make a difference by sort of rinsing
dish not rinsing dishes before they go
in the dishwasher or freezing bread
before it goes mouldy
and she was criticized for sort of
diminishing the gravity of the issue
but actually
that all of that didn't happen by
accident allegra stratton made those
comments to keep the issue in the
headlines perhaps inviting ridicule but
getting people to think about how
important climate change is and the part
that ordinary people can play in
tackling it so i don't think it was an
accident that boris johnson chose that
strategy and the way he delivered the
speech certainly pushed it up to the top
of the headlines and i think the
ancillary point is that there is a
concern amongst world leaders and
negotiators and scientists actually that
there's alarm fatigue happening that the
science is so the warnings are so urgent
and so diabolical um so catastrophic uh
that people are starting to switch off
so injecting a bit of a huge bit of
humor into these things is no bad thing
hannah thanks very much indeed
well as we've discussed the prime
minister told the un then that kermit
the frog was wrong when he complained
that it wasn't easy being green and on
today's debate we're going to be asking
the founder of climate in color joycelyn
longdon and the director of climate
imperative bruce nillis who they agree
with mr johnson or the muppet
now a report published today suggests
that boris johnson may still have his
work cut out it concluded that the vast
majority of uk industries will miss
their net zero emissions targets without
urgent action from the government the
report by zurich uk and the university
of the west of england found only five
of 17 sectors are decreasing their
emissions while seven are actually
seeing emissions rise it wants the
government to implement nationwide
strategies to help industries overcome
carbon challenges
and mr johnson's successor as london
mayor sadiq khan has warned that climate
change is the biggest threat facing the
capital right now according to analysis
by city hall nearly half of london's
hospitals one in five schools and a
quarter of the city's railway stations
are already at risk of flooding
mr khan said time is running out to
tackle the climate crisis
the government's being urged to suspend
funding for rainforest protection in the
democratic republic of congo until the
country extends its logging ban the drc
plans to lift a 19-year suspension on
new industrial logging in the congo
basin the second largest rainforest in
the world and absorbs much more carbon
than it releases a global coalition of
more than 40 non-governmental
organizations says reopening the
country's forests to loggers would be a
disaster for the
climate and ford is in talks to build a
new generation of electric transmission
systems an essential part of electric
cars at its uk plant
bosses are expected to make a decision
within weeks about whether to build the
new systems at halewood on merseyside
ford says its passenger vehicle lineup
in europe will be all electric by 2030.
now a merseyside school has put climate
change at the center of its curriculum
and now saint vincent's in liverpool
where most of the pupils are blind or
deaf is inspiring other schools in the
region to go green imsaman rasheed went
to find out more from the school's
teachers and students
it may look like a typical school on the
outskirts of liverpool but saint
vincent's is having global impact
welcome to our polytunnel so we've been
growing tomatoes we've been going
carrots these apples are great
abian knows by the time he leaves school
climate change may have forced more than
a hundred million people into poverty
and being visually impaired doesn't stop
him tackling the issue head-on
it makes me feel very bad that we're
actually
burning fossil fuel making this earth
hotter
and
sometimes killing the animals and so
on it makes me feel a bit upset and
want me wanting me to
see if you can try and save the planet
for the last decade this school has been
building climate action into its
curriculum and for some of its students
their activism has taken them as far as
the united nations
now they're set to share their green
vision
across the country
as a specialist school we can be free in
the curriculum it means we can do things
for climate action the colleagues can
then replicate in their curriculum once
we've piloted it there is still a
nervousness to move away from the sats
but we have to hence we can be a hub of
best practice and we can share that with
our colleagues
it means a network across merseyside
will replicate st vincent's successful
education program they're also leading a
group of nearly 500 schools that have
pledged to go net zero by 2030. up and
down the country hundreds of schools are
following the inspiring example of saint
vincent and really responding to the
calls of young people to preserve the
planet for future generations and
children really get it they just say
come on world leaders time that you took
the action put these in bags i'm going
to send these to cop26 and in just over
a month's time these climate warriors
will head to glasgow where they'll meet
world leaders and offer them some seeds
for change let's see do it um visually
impaired and blind people are doing you
better do it
save our planet
a stark message from a boy fighting to
save a planet he can't even fully see
now he wants you to do the same in zaman
rashid sky news liverpool
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'm going to be joined by the
economist joycelyn longdon and bruce
nillas the director of climate think
tank climate imperative they're standing
by ready and waiting right now we're
going to be discussing whether it really
is that easy for the uk economy to go
green and how young people should learn
about climate change that's coming up
[Music]
the numbers were increasing even before
the pandemic so what we know is that
children's mental health unfortunately
has been getting worse and it tends to
be the most vulnerable who are most
affected for example those living in
poverty or on disability or who are
socially excluded but the pandemic
really had a disastrous effect for some
young people we know that lots of
children young people had a tough time
but they've been resilient and they've
bounced back so this is not the majority
but for those the school closures and
the disruption losing out on that
structure and predictability and routine
of school the contact with friends for
some young people school is also a place
where their needs get picked up and
where they can
access support so it's just had a really
negative effect for some young people
and our services which have never been
funded properly to begin with are just
buckling under the demand
and what we usually want to do in
children's mental health is to intervene
as early as we can we have effective
treatments and the earlier you intervene
the better so i do really worry about
children young people who are waiting
for treatment and the worry is that
certainly for some the difficulties are
just going to get worse because for some
children young people they actually
don't need that much help they might
just need one or two sessions with
someone who can support them but we then
also need that link into
you know specialist mental health
services and to have enough trained
clinicians to do this the other place
where children young people are and can
get help are is at schools and we're
calling on the educational secretary to
prioritize this as a really urgent area
of need and we have mental health
support teams being ruled out but that
needs to be accelerated all schools need
to be set up when it's great to see
children young people back in school and
you can see how just getting back into
their usual activities seeing their
friends and also just seeing normal life
being re-established is what they need
and it's also really helpful for them to
see the adults in their lives becoming a
little bit more relaxed about things
getting back into their normal
activities so you know most children
young people will be absolutely fine but
it's really important also for parents
to just keep tuned in seeing how they're
doing noticing if there are any major
changes in how their children are if for
example if they're just not you know
coming out and talking to them and
joining them at meal times if they seem
to have lost interest in school or
activities if they're suddenly really
restricting their diet it's just kind of
keeping an eye on that as it's so
important
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Music]
did you know if you use less energy we
can reduce air pollution
like turning off the light yep
we have an east-west split on friday
with western parts saying a lot of low
cloud
patchy drizzle some light rain and most
eastern areas seeing some early
brightness at least and hanging on to
the brightness parts of east anglia and
the southeast where temperatures again
could reach around 23 degrees celsius 73
degrees fahrenheit so still very warm
for this time in september
still quite a breezy day with the
strongest winds in the far north and
those once again are going to help the
air pollution levels stay low right
across the country
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with the
founder of climate in color joycelyn
london and bruce niles the executive
director of climate imperative so
welcome to both of you really good to
have you on the show
and first of all boris johnson disagreed
with a very famous muppet in his address
to the un
permit the frog
sang
it's not easy being green
you remember that one
i want you to know that he was wrong
so how easy is it to be green
let's ask that to jocelyn london first
of all so boris johnson clearly trying
to encourage other countries to go green
but is he right to say that it's the
easy option
um i think my question would be if it
was so easy to be green why boris
johnson since the paris agreement in
2015 has
um contributed 4 billion plans to the
oil and gas industry um that's not very
green
why is he not cancelling the campbell
oil field up near scotland um so if it
is so easy to be green why hasn't boris
johnson himself made kind of the most
pressing green decisions uh for this
country
bruce what do you make of that do you
think that's fair i mean boris johnson
would no doubt argue that the uk has a
good record on cutting back on its
dependence on coal he'd say that they've
got world leading climate targets
they're going to announce their strategy
on meeting them in the coming weeks do
you think it's
fair to criticize the uk's record on
this and should boris johnson actually
get some credit for what's been achieved
this week
i think it's a story of two tales one is
yes there's progress but there's a lot
more needs to be done right if it was as
easy as jocelyn said
we wouldn't have this conversation and
so the opportunity we have is how does
government how does boris johnson how do
governments around the world help people
accelerate this transition from fossil
fuels because it's not as easy as it
should be to help transition to electric
cars to electric key pumps there's
enormous things we can do but we need
the government to be helping make it
easier than it is today okay and so
let's take a look jocelyn shall we at
what that means for the consumer and and
how easy that could be and we'll have a
look at what boris johnson actually said
he said we have nothing to fear and
everything to gain from the green
industrial revolution so justin what do
you think at the moment of how easy it
is for a consumer to go green and what
will they gain
i think there are some obvious uh
changes that everyone can make that
we've heard time and time again eating
less meat taking more journeys by foot
or by bike flying less and obviously
those are quite easy actions to take but
the more infrastructural
decisions that we have to make to be
more green are in the hands of the
government and are currently not as easy
as they could be uh we don't have an
amazing and affordable transport network
for people to you know maybe not drive
to work or um
depending on where they're living and so
i think there's a lot more to do
infrastructurally from the government to
make these decisions easier so again as
bruce said it's a tell of two stories
there are some um actions that we can
take that are really simple really easy
and everyone should be doing them but a
lot more
to be done systematically well yes bruce
do you agree with that is this down to
governments to try and make some of
these decisions uh more attractive and
cheaper as well joslyn was talking about
transport but there's also the cost of
insulating and heating your homes as
well isn't there is it down to the
government to make that cheaper and
easier for us
that's right i mean obviously there's a
lot we can do as individuals we can um
do a lot of things in our daily life but
we're not going to solve this problem
unless we get
governments and businesses stepping up
to make this easier for everybody
so as you're thinking about things like
when your water heater breaks
is there a program in place to help
people afford to make the transition to
a clean non-fossil fuel alternative
those kind of programs rests with the
government helping make sure those
programs are in place and that's what we
need across the world today so that we
can get this problem solved in the next
10 to 20 years yeah and joycelyn bruce
mentioned corporations and companies
there what role does the private sector
have
the role of the private sector is to
make sure that they are working in line
with
the targets that we have as a community
this is this takes all of us and um
companies at the moment aren't taking so
much responsibility and are more
interested in greenwashing consumers um
instead of actually being truthful being
honest and making the hard changes and
the hard decisions that they will have
to make in order for us to reach the
goals that we need to
is it the truth bruce that ultimately
it's going to make good financial sense
to go green we heard boris johnson
talking about it being the lucrative
option
is is that true to say that that's
ultimately going to help encourage
businesses to take that course
i think that's one of the most exciting
developments in the last five to 10
years which is the price of clean energy
today is cheaper than fossil fuels
thinking about the gas crisis in the uk
and around europe right now the
continued reliance on fossil fuels is
terrible for our climate but it's also
terrible for our economy
so you see factories having to shut down
because they can't afford to buy natural
gas that wouldn't happen if we had a
clean renewable economy and so there's
enormous upside today
the problem is we have um private
companies who are
lobbying on behalf of oil and gas who
are trying to slow down this transition
and currently the governments are
listening to them more um than the rest
of us but bruce there are jobs in those
industries as well aren't there and
people are worried about losing those
jobs
enormous i grew up in in the northwest
england and i go back to visit my mom
and it is amazing to see the wind
turbines right those are real jobs
making steel putting them in the ground
and operating them so yes there are
enormous upsides
economically but also for the job
transition so that people have good
family supporting wages
okay let's move on to our second subject
shall we because uh just before the
break we saw a rather inspiring piece
about a school in merseyside with
students there taking the lead on
climate change and inspiring other
children in the region so we want to ask
the question how should we be teaching
about climate change and bruce i'm going
to start with you on this
should climate change be part of the
curriculum you're in the united states
at the moment what happens there at the
moment
so
um
this year has been the climate change
has been coming through the front door
like a battering ram right one in three
americans has been impacted by climate
change this year either super storms or
wildfires
and i have an eight-year-old daughter
she reads the headlines she understands
something is wrong and so it is critical
we help explain to our children the
science of climate change why is it
happening and what do we need to do to
solve it so that they
as they become voters and actors in um
in the future that they are a part of
the solution and understand what we need
to do to help solve this problem so
education is absolutely critical i
didn't learn about climate change until
i went to university um that's too late
we need everyone including
our children in high school or grammar
school to be helping solve this problem
today
joyce what do you think about this
because i just want to show one
statistic to our viewers
one in five children in the uk reports
nightmares about climate change i mean
it's a difficult subject to broach isn't
it with young children when
some of the news around it seems quite
scary
yeah and as bruce says children are
they're not you know they're not hidden
they're not um you know they they read
the news they understand what's going on
um and it's actually up to us the adults
the schools their parents to support
them on that journey and to be honest
with them about what is going on and why
it's happening and i think a huge part
of alleviating this anxiety is actually
taking action and being able to see
adults their leaders governments take
action
and actually
sit in their roles um of making positive
change that is going to be inspiring and
that is going to be empowering and it is
going to take away from this huge amount
of fear that there is right now because
that fear is coming um it's stemming a
lot from this helplessness and it's
overwhelmed that things aren't going to
get better well one way that children
have actually taken action that we've
seen around the world is these school
strikes bruce i mean do you approve of
those there are plenty of people here
that worry that children shouldn't be
missing out on vital education and
missing days of school and if they're
going to have their voices heard why not
do it at the weekend
well so one of my most um
important memories of growing up was
and similarly a terrifying time during
um
the nuclear disarmament debate in the
1970s and 1980s one of the most
impactful things was going with my
church group down to london and hyde
park and and urging the government
uh to address the threat of nuclear
war
having children engaged to me was just a
critical step of understanding it and
also understanding that we can do
something about it so i'm a very big fan
of helping
inspiring children to get engaged in
civic engagement so that they can be a
part of shaping the future and just
another quick word from you on that do
you think children should be allowed
time off school to go on marches or
should they be spending time in the
classroom very briefly
yeah i don't think all education happens
in the classroom you have to get out
there you have to be part of it you have
to know what's going on in politics that
is also learning that is education for
them and so if that's what it takes to
get our leaders to make action and to
make children feel like they're part of
the solution then yeah i think it's uh
well worth the time
okay well uh joyce in london and bruce
nillis really good to have you on the
show thanks very much indeed for joining
us here tonight
you